this was supposed to be the decisive
week for brexit but when how and
possibly even whether the UK will leave
the EU remains unclear after stormy
debate a partial victory for Boris
Johnson a majority in parliament
approved his withdrawal deal in
principle but they voted down his
timetable now the ball is in Brussels
Court will it agree to the extension
reluctantly requested by the Prime
Minister can Westminster seal a deal
[Music]
[Music]
and we have three brexit Watchers with
us here on to the point to help us
penetrate the fog emanating from London
Derrick's Kelly works for the Irish
Times and he says Boris Johnson and his
brexit brothers have paralysed Europe
for three years now they're a you depart
has become a Deal or No Deal game show
but it can't always get worse and it
will and it's a pleasure to welcome John
Werth he is a British blogger living
here in Berlin he says a general
election before Christmas is now Boris
Johnson's only way out of his
self-inflicted brexit mess and we're
very happy to have ventolin from breda
with us she works for the British
magazine The Economist and she says MPs
are kicking the can down the road which
means brexit is less and less likely by
the end of the month so Derek you say
that Johnson and his brexit brothers in
your words have paralysed Europe but
aren't we in fact seeing at least a
little bit of movement now at least
there has been agreement agreement on a
deal which in fact is something Teresa
may never achieved yeah there's been
technically an preliminary agreement I
mean it's tiny steps forward but there
could easily be more steps back I mean
we've been doing this for a very long
time it's a signal of just how poisonous
the British political system is now that
the Parliament doesn't trust its own
Prime Minister they don't trust him that
they will agree to this and then he'll
double-cross the more he will be
double-crossed by his brexit ears the
heartbreakers ears and they will have a
no deal breaks it so it's a sign of how
bad things are that this is all they
could do this week and we don't know
what's coming so yes it's progress if
you want but from the very low base so
the parliamentarians venda lean are
asking for more influence more details
more time you say that amounts to kick
in the can down the road but isn't it
pretty understandable that they have
let's say woken up out of their stupor
and are actually making some demands
given the magnitude of what's happening
it's absolutely understandable because
it's a very complex undertaking they
have to read through hundreds of pages
or more than a 100 pages of very
detailed very complex stuff and you
can't do that in a few days even though
the Prime Minister tried to get them to
do that by the end of the month so it is
absolutely understandable the only thing
is of course if you do then ask for yet
another extension that again creates
uncertainty and the possibility of
further obstacles or problems which is
of course why Boris Johnson didn't kept
insisting no we have to leave by the
31st of October which increasingly looks
unlikely and unfeasible so John you say
a general election could wind up being
Boris Johnson's only way out explain
that to us if you would because in fact
he does have approval on this deal why
would he want to reopen it so to speak
essentially because he only got approval
because he put the Parliamentarians or
potentially put the parliamentarians
under enormous time pressure they didn't
actually really know what was in this
deal since basically give me this deal
now and what the parliamentarians have
said is hang on a minute we need more
time to analyze this and when they start
looking into it they see details with
regard to all of the different aspects
the economic relationship the Northern
Ireland border where they have problems
and ultimately that 330 politicians that
Boris Johnson had back in his deal he
that were whittled down it will go lower
and lower as the week's go by and Boris
Johnson has understood that so if he
says okay let's risk a general election
I'll go into the general election
promising brexit and hopefully come back
with a majority so ultimately it would
be a gamble but that way he might
increase the number of conservative
members of parliament and then be able
to get a much larger majority to make
sure that his brexit is secured so I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
implications of an election in a moment
but first let us ourselves explore a
little bit of what this deal does
contain so as John just mentioned
Ireland especially Northern Ireland a
major sticking point the dup party that
used to be friends of the Tories is
saying it's been sold out can you just
briefly tell us Derek what exactly is
the agreement now on Ireland is it
workable and is it going to be
acceptable in the end yes there's a
compromise on both sides and Northern
Ireland in future will be sort of in
between the EU and the UK it will be
officially part legally part of the you
a customs union so if UK does deals with
the US it can profit from that but
there's a back door and that back door
will keep the border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic which is
staying in the you open so basically if
you were to be positive about it they
have the best of all possible worlds EU
membership unofficially pragmatically on
a day to day basis traveling over and
back across the open border but they
also will have access to these wonderful
new global Britain trade deals that
London will be agreeing so they got the
best of all possible worlds but the
people in northern aren't who are loyal
to the Queen they don't want to be they
don't want special treatment they just
want to be as good you UK citizens
anyone else and they think that as time
goes on and the trade differences
between the UK and EU get bigger the gap
between Northern Ireland and the rest of
the UK will become great bigger and then
they will sort of on a slippery slope
towards United on which they want to
avoid but let's talk a little bit about
timing
as we said Johnson had sworn he would
leave the EU by October 31st but now he
submitted this very very ambivalent
request to the EU for an extension take
us through that if you would well Boris
Johnson said he'd rather die in a ditch
and then then leave the EU later than
October 31st now he's not dead he may be
but he's not that what he did is
something very unusual he sent because
by law by the Bend Act he was required
to ask for an extension so he sent that
letter for demanding the extension but
without signing it and probably without
putting a stamp on the letter and maybe
even smudging the ink a little bit and
then he sent another letter which he
signed where he says well you know I'm
actually against the extension which was
of course playing to his face there was
all part of his posturing and you know
he's a great theatrical theatre maker so
that's what it is you know he he will
need an extension it's impossible to get
it through by the end of the month but
because he promised he wouldn't do that
he that's this whole charade of not
signing the letter and pretending you
know he's doing something he's obliged
to do because his enemies imposed it on
him so it seems the ball is now in
Brussels court and from what we're
hearing decision-makers there are torn
between frustration and the fervent
desire
to ensure an orderly withdrawal let's go
now to DWS brussels bureau chief max
Hoffman
hi max hope you can hear and see us we
can you tell me first of all what is the
mood in Brussels are people there
basically saying we have just got to get
this thing over well first of all the
mood is that the ball is not at all in
the court of the European Union but they
still feel they need guidance by Boris
Johnson what's the plan because as you
know the brexit deal is on ice even the
brexit the withdrawal bill which is the
legislation behind that deal is on ice
at the moment and Boris Johnson has
always said if there is an extension
then he will pull that bill and he will
call for a snap elections so does he
really want to do that how much time
would he need to do that if not if he
still wants to pass that deal how long
will it take him to get it through the
UK House of Commons if at all and the
thinking here is if we know how long he
needs to do that then we'll give him
that and maybe 5 days extra and then
he'll have the time he needs but so far
no signals like that from the UK so
there is frustration about that and you
know it's been going on for three and a
half years it's no miracle that many
here just want to get it over with but
with a deal
so what's your guess where where this is
how this is going to play out when will
we have a decision out of Brussels and
what kind of timeframe do you think will
then be talking about you ambassadors
met on Wednesday and it appeared that in
the room they were all in favor of an
extension the question is just how long
the French won a short technical
extension maybe even three to four weeks
and countries like Germany say give them
the extension they asked for which is
until the 31st of January they will meet
again on Friday and might get a decision
there what they want to avoid it all
cost is another summit another brexit
summit that gives even more attention to
Boris Johnson max Hoffman thank you very
much for being with us so let's pick up
on that John and come back to this
general election idea that you had
mentioned in your opening statement now
Boris Johnson had said if in fact it's a
long extension he will maybe
what to go through with a general
election but apparently his party is
very divided so what's your assessment
first of all on where the Tories stand
and then we're gonna talk a little bit
about labour so basically the
Conservative Party thinks it could win a
general election it's ten percentage
points ahead of the Labour Party in the
opinion polls Boris Johnson is more
popular than Jeremy Corbyn the the
Labour Party leader but the
Conservatives are nervous because they
were also 10 pin points ahead in the
opinion polls back in 2017 and look what
happened there because Jeremy Corbyn
caught up then with Theresa May the then
Conservative leader there's also the
case that many conservatives want to get
breaks it done and say that get practice
it on first and then have a general
election because the population will
then thank us for having managed to get
Britain out of the European Union
because there is that gentleman waiting
in the wings Nigel Farage the very
well-known member of the European
Parliament who will come roaring back
he will essentially say this brexit deal
that Boris Johnson's negotiated that's
not a real brexit we want a real and
radical brexit out-and-out now and Boris
Johnson fears that he would lose support
to the brexit Party and that might allow
opposition parties in and so that's the
reason for the nervousness winter is
also coming and no one really likes
doing election campaigns in November and
December when it's rainy and cold and
unpleasant and that might also mean that
election turnouts may also be down so it
would be a very very strange election
but ultimately on balance I still think
the Conservatives will go for that
because they see the weakness of the
Labour Party just now and where it is
labor play out in all of this we heard
now that Jeremy Corbyn is saying yes he
might want to go on go ahead with a
general election what would likely be
the results for labour I think it could
be disastrous he seems to be getting
into the detail of brags at which stage
nobody wants to hear any detail anymore
it's a binary decision breaks it now yes
no and he's saying this deal that has
been negotiated is worse than 3 sanae's
deal that it would undermine workers
rights and so on in the UK because
Britain might want to sort of undercut
the the rest of the European Union and
becomes of a competitive singapore and
attempts but this is he's getting into
detail at the end of
day two people trust Jeremy Corbyn I
think the answer is really no and
there's been this terribly damaging
thing about anti-semitism at ISM within
the Labour Party Labour Party has been
consuming itself I mean it almost
doesn't need an opposition party like
two Tories it's fighting itself I don't
really know how attractive a proposition
labour is at the moment with this leader
but of course that's for the British
voters to decide position it says it
wants a second you referendum it's taken
labour three years to come to a
relatively clear position so ultimately
if you want Britain to remain in the
European Union you can now relatively
safely vote for either labour all the
Liberal Democrats all the greens or the
Scottish National Party whichever might
have the best chance in the constituency
in which you live that might save them
but a second referendum two years ago
perhaps might have enthusiasm at this
stage even friends of mine who want to
stay in the European Union they say even
they are saying get brexit done which is
a classic Tory populist expression
clearly the outcome of any vote would
depend on public opinion and as as we're
hearing opinion in Britain is
increasingly polarized let's hear the
voices of some of those who went onto
the streets just this past week to speak
out
we don't one hat we want to have people
being the majority because we are
British I think it's a terrible deal for
the country and it's a terrible deal for
the poorest people in the country as a
bridge here I'm disgusted with all the
delays boys wants to push real things in
a way but we can't have a say on it just
to save his own face basically he wants
to be the guy the battle lines are drawn
but what does the majority in Britain
want
let's get vender lean to tell us that
what is the majority in Britain want and
given the level of polarization that we
see there would a new election resolve
anything at all well it would give Boris
Johnson probably a farmer mandate
because remember he's not elected he's
never been elected to the post of Prime
Minister and at the moment the mood in
the country seems to be that seems to be
that the majority are that he would get
a majority if you held elections
tomorrow so he is of course keen on that
because he would strengthen him and
strengthen his hold on power and if he
did get a majority is there any chance
that he would back out of this deal that
the European research group the hardline
brexit ears possibly would gain more
influence that they could use to push
through a kind of a No Deal solution
would you is there any chance we'd see
some kind of radical development like
that I think that's unlikely because
although it's not a good deal and Boris
Johnson is afraid and he's worried about
the chaos that could ensue with a new
deal a brexit he's he's intelligent in
half and pragmatic enough to know how
dangerous it is and they could have not
quite a civil war but I mean really
chaotic scenes in in Britain so he's
very keen to avoid that and all this
grandstanding and saying you know rather
die and they did all the illest
that he's been saying was just to apply
more pressure in order to get a deer
than he always wanted an agreement I'm
quite certain of that
Derek we talked about the majority and
what they want in Britain but where do
people in Scotland and Ireland stand it
has often been said that one of the
terrible side effects of brexit could be
essentially breaking apart the United
Kingdom do you think that is where we're
heading what are people in Ireland and
Scotland saying now yeah well people in
our were you know there's no good breaks
it but of all the breaks of deals this
is this is fine can we just agree on
this what was just the current brakes it
deal because the the primary achievement
of the Irish government in Dublin was no
border that the the status quo in last
20 years was preserved but there's a big
asterisk beside that and that asterisk
is that all this technical stuff of
trade and collecting tariffs and
Northern Ireland will work between the
British Isles in future so there's a big
if where will this actually work and on
the other hand people in Ireland are
wondering eventually people in Northern
I would realise they've gotten quite a
sweetheart deal if it works but then the
question is yeah why didn't the Scots
get it you've already seen that it's
coming out and so so the unintended law
of unintended consequences could be that
we kept the border open and between
Northern Ireland and the Republic but
what happens if Scotland gets up some
momentum and this is like the steroids
that the nationalists in in Scotland
have been needed to break away so you
know we could have saved our land and
broken off the UK on on our neighbor
island so yeah who knows where it's
going next issue John there is a
palpable longing for resolution we heard
max saying there's a that that's the
case in Brussels we heard people in that
film talking about their wish for yes a
resolution yet experts are saying that
even if a brexit deal goes through let's
say by the end of the year or early next
year there will still then be another
chapter of wrangling of uncertainty
surrounding trade because Britain will
then have to very quickly negotiate new
bilateral trade agreements with the EU
its biggest trading partner and with its
longed-for partner the u.s. is that
process truly going to be as difficult
and painful as what we've seen along the
brexit it will probably be even worse
although maybe it won't have quite the
kind of public sort of debate it's
definitely going to be much more
time-consuming and much more complex
than what we've seen so far and the idea
should be that the framework for that
deal should even be in place by the end
of 2020 so just over 12 months from now
which is impossible to achieve so
ultimately we might get over this
deadline now but we've got another
deadline coming up in just over 12
months which is going to have to
probably itself be extended and also if
we look at for example it took the
European Union seven years to negotiate
a trade deal with Canada and that was
about much more minimal issues and
Britain is going to have to negotiate a
trade deal with the European Union so
we're going to be looking at something
of upwards of five years to get
everything sorted out for the trade deal
between the UK and the European Union if
you're tired of brexit the best way is
to say essentially hold a second
referendum and stay and then at least
the sort of cliffhanger waiting for the
next deadline will go away if you
actually go through with this now and
this is only the first of a series of
deadlines which are going to be coming
up in the next few years so maybe it
won't be the topic of everyday
discussion so much more but this is
going to be a nightmare for a decade for
the UK if they do see this bit through
let's see whether either of your fellow
guests think that that could really
still be an option referendum and
backing away from brexit at all ventolin
can you even imagine that that could
still be an option I agree with Derek I
think that is highly unlikely by now I
think there was a time let's say a year
ago when when there was a lot of
momentum for a second referendum and
asked the economists were in favor of
that because we argued that the first
time they people really didn't know what
they were voting on so so we thought
with a heavy heart because normally when
obviously must respect the results of a
referendum we thought a second
referendum is a good idea but I think by
now the time is it's it's too late so
that window of opportunity has closed
and I think it's it's highly unlikely
the Terek in a way Joe
this argument is promised on people
voting on the basis of facts and
projections and the clear balance
between costs and benefits of brexit
looks like it probably will be negative
for Great Britain to put it mildly
yet that's really not what people are
deciding on the basis of is it aren't we
looking at something that has become as
we saw in the film absolutely emotional
I think it always was emotional it's
always been a very deep need it's a it's
a struggle within the British soul who
are we are we part of something bigger
are we better off alone and the detail
is just distracting us and I you can
really see it as you know living in
Ireland we know the British quite well
probably better than other people in
Europe because of our interesting
history but I find it really telling
that nobody in Britain really if any
other country in Europe had held up a
continent for three years I think some
people would be embarrassed perhaps some
people be ashamed some people might
apologize they feel that they can do
this for another three years perhaps and
I don't know if the rest of Europe is
really interested would there would be
more extensions and talk of extension
the patience and so on but this notion
that they'd even be wanted in the
European Union at this stage nobody in
Britain seems to be asking that question
it's one thing to say we'd like to stay
does anyone else really want them at
this stage because if they stay there
will be effectively a political civil
war in the country they will not be very
productive European Union members on the
other side if they go a current movement
bearing in mind that there is a majority
of the British population that wants to
remain we saw more than 1 million people
on the streets of London just a week ago
arguing the case for remain in the
European Union and for holding a second
referendum 60 million not you're not
going to get a million leavers going out
demonstrating and there's never been a
group that kind of groundswell of
support you've got the biggest
grassroots pro-eu movement that any
European country is in the UK just now
too late you might argue but bear in
mind however there is no deal that you
can get through the current House of
Commons because there is no majority for
anything
the only majority of is for anything is
against No Deal and so ultimately what's
your way of unlocking all of this you've
tried unlocking it through parliamentary
means over the
three years that's ultimately failed a
new election mayor Lockett but again as
we've discussed it may not so ultimately
the solution if you really can bear with
it is essentially to say a new election
romain parties try to manage to organize
as best they can to try to at least deny
the conservatives of majority and nearly
move forward to a second referendum some
point in the middle of 2020 because it
might not be nice for the European Union
but it's definitely the least worst out
this assumes they we didn't have the
detail back then and the whole premise
of a second referendum is if people knew
the detail they will vote differently
people are not going to read the details
Ireland is the country of referendum
people go and vote on referendum new
European treaties when we ask them what
they're voting on they haven't read
anything so we're assuming people would
be will now that they have the detail
will willingly make themselves more
informed than before but we've had three
or four years of poison they're just
going to vote with their gut like I did
the last time
at the moment based on the current
opinion polls they will vote to remain
but very tightly and then back to the
start again
the other alternative putting Britain
out with an inadequate deal and with all
of the tensions that we've discussed
about Ireland is also about solution so
ultimately you've got to choose the
least worst solution here and the least
worst solution remains an election
followed by by it by a reference so
Evangeline let me get you to weigh you
know here and I'm going to come back to
our title because I'm going to ask all
of you to answer that title question can
Westminster seal a deal is the title
question John in a way is saying no
where do you stand and if you say yes
when and what's it gonna look like Oh to
the point so yes I think Westminster can
strike a deal and and it's not going to
be a bad good deal it's not going to be
pretty but I think I think we are now
maybe on the way of doing that when it's
the big question I think the most likely
deadline now is the 31st of January they
are going to ask for an extension and
then this is the 31st of Jeremy but I
mean with with a big question mark but
that at the moment I think it's the most
likely time to ever so my answer is yes
it can't strike a deal and the most
likely deadline is the 31st of January
Derek unfortunately I breaks my heart to
say it but the European you has more
important things now to discuss then
Britain and Britain's problems need to
be saw
in Britain so I I say with a heavy heart
go with God but go and when when will it
happen possible because then we can get
back to what's really important the
European Union's future in the world
trying to battle between populace trying
to battle what's what's our security
issue water on migration policies what
kind of Europe do we want Britain has
been distracting us for a long enough
and in other words you're saying
Westminster will seal the deal and you
say farewell yeah and we might want to
apologize for wasting your time for
three years but I don't really expect
that apology good talk shows
John last word to you are you saying
Westminster won't seal a deal
Westminster wants this Westminster this
composition of House of Commons won't
seal a deal it needs a general election
after the general election either you
get this deal because Forrest Ronson is
strengthened or alternatively Britain is
on the track to a second referendum okay
thanks very much to all of you we'll see
whose prediction comes true and thanks
to you out there for joining in see you
again on to the point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]